right now I'm just going to put the
pressure suit on and then install it
into the seat and that requires plugging
in all my systems so this can take a
while but here we go I became interested
in building pressure suit when I started
thinking well I won't be going to space
I won't be going to Mars but I will try
to go as close as I can I have a budget
at Ace Hardware of $20.00 a weekend and
I've put in basically a year of research
and in three years of building I looked
at in dozens of patents and dozens of
NASA reports and I started to realize
how essentially simple the pressure suit
was and then I started to realize oh I
can actually build this myself I can
make one of these that I'm willing to
stake my life on myself I was foolish
and made the zipper go down I need to
reverse the zipper that comes up because
I can't reach it so my mom happens to be
in town and how many people get to be
put into their pressure suit my mom
people have occasionally said that this
is it's obviously dangerous some people
have suggested maybe it's beyond
dangerous and into foolhardy I disagree
I think that that is said out of
ignorance of how essentially simple the
system is we have this idea that the
only people who can do this is NASA or
highly funded research arms or the Air
Force or whoever who's got all this
money how that goes on and man it closes
it
I've done a test of my breathing gas and
they don't know anything about the
history of those five years before the
war where people built these and they
worked
if they could build these from
rubberized canvas and these very few
components in the 1930s surely seventy
years later I can do the same here at
home and so that's the end of one
pressure test and I didn't run the
cooling system today as a tiny leak and
tiny leaks are exactly the battle the
constant battle is knocking out little
tiny leaks and it's one screw and
actually I fixed the screw and then then
the hose unplugged by itself so tiny
details like that or what I'm knocking
out piece by piece one by one weekend by
weekend
you